oui
après la mort de patrice pelât la
révolte de max théret à droite comme à
gauche le milieu politique reste discret
lionel jospin et michel rocard passe aux
téléspectateurs une première cet après
midi c'était sur antenne 2 et fr3 14
morts surtout des jeunes abel sport dans
un immeuble du centre ville
un incendie a ravagé en pleine nuit
nouvelles tensions dans la terre rouge
dit l'islam en force
c'est la nouvelle donne politique en
algérie reportage
bonsoir la mort de patrice pelât a
provoqué la colère d'un autre inculpé de
la paix rhdp chine et c max théret il a
dit sa colère dans le monde publié ce
soir c'est cette affaire qui a tué cela
dit il cette justice sur la voie
publique
ces apprentis shérif il y a deux mois
ajoute monsieur terré monsieur peu là
était aussi solide que ces arbres de
sologne
patrick cela avait été très affectée en
effet par son inculpation patrice pelât
qui est mort hier à l'âge de 70 ans d'un
arrêt du coeur était un ami proche du
président mitterrand il en avait parlé
de cette amitié à dominique lori healy a
à peu près un an et coûtait président je
n'ai connu
il ya fort longtemps c'était en 1941 il
nous sommes connus d'un camp de
prisonniers
et d'ailleurs le commando dans lequel
j'étais était spécialisée dans les
pouilles âge des prisonniers français
c'est comme ça que j'ai fait sa
connaissance comme je le disais à berck
philosophe disait que deux hommes qui se
sont appuyés ensemble se voue une amitié
indestructible les événements la vie et
prouve ce philosophe avait raison oui
c'est un effet c'est un homme que je
connais moins sur deux aspects bien sûr
le politique que tout le monde connaît
mais bon j'aurais surtout parlé de
l'homme simplement ce qu'ils avaient à
dire que c'est un homme qui est très
simple qui aime
la nature et qui aime ses amis qui a
avant tout un homme d'une grande
fidélité conçu d'identité qu'on
rencontre rarement et nous arrive
souvent malheureusement d'aller voir
d'anciens camarades anciens prisonniers
de guerre d'anciens camarades de la
résistance d'autres familles qui a
rencontré ou en étant sans jamais ne les
abandonne ce matin président mitterrand
a reçu à l'elysée madame jacqueline plat
la veuve de l'industriel et l'un de ses
deux fils bruno gex il n'y avait là rien
d'officiel simplement l'entrée discrète
de la veuve d'un ami du président de la
république madame jacqueline pol a
soutenu par l'un de ses fils à son
arrivée à l'elysée qu'elle quittera une
demi heure plus tard la discrétion
toujours à la sortie du conseil des
ministres une seule consigne le silence
chacun comprendra par respect pour la
peine des familles et des proches de
monsieur peu là le porte parole du
gouvernement ne fasse pas de commentaire
la discrétion et même le refus
catégorique de parler à la
ferté-saint-aubin le village de roger
patrice pelât
il n'y aura pas de déclaration de
monsieur le maire dit ce qu'il a dit
qu'il ne ferait pas de déclaration
reviendra pas soir aucun autre
commentaire ne sera fait à 5 km de là
cette magnifique propriété de sologne
c'est là que roger patrice pelât venait
passer ses moments de détente à l'abri
des regards indiscrets
deux précisions à propos de la sphère
pechiney bien sûr l'action en justice
est en elle-même puisque monsieur poulat
est mort quant à la caution de quatre
millions cinq cent mille francs qui
avait été payée par l'industriel pour
conserver sa liberté cette caution sera
prochainement rembourser à ses héritiers
les réactions dans la classe politique
elles sont presque toutes de la même
tonalité une quasi unanimité pour
demander plus de respect pour les
personnes mises en cause dans ce type
d'affaires véronique saint olive
max théret l'ami intime s'est engagée
maintenant je vais me battre non
seulement pour moi mais pour lui cet
homme était innocent sur google earth
et par la mort de roger patrice pelât
qui était un honnête homme un grand
résistant
pour sa disparition mais me et je pense
que il a été durement atteint par les
événements que vous savez et sa
disparition tragique doit donner à
réfléchir à tous ce que je sais c'est
que patrice pelata un grand résistant et
qu'il mérite à ce titre la gratitude de
la nation ce que je suis aussi c'est que
il a été pendant 40 ans l'ami de
françois mitterrand et on sait que
françois mitterrand est un homme qui
pour lequel l'ami qui compte beaucoup
alors aujourd'hui je penserai tristesse
de françois mitterrand peu de réactions
au rpr seule edouard balladur a exprimé
son sentiment de tristesse devant la
mort d'un homme
il a ajouté il faut que notre vie
publique ne s'accommode pas de jugements
précipités ou de déclarations
péremptoires une très grande discrétion
des hommes politiques c'est ce soir ce
qu'on peut noter jean lieu scène mais
vous l'avez vu à quelques exceptions
près toute la classe politique observe
une certaine réserve
depuis la mort de roger patrice pelât et
même pierre bérégovoy edouard balladur
se retrouvent pour affirmer sobrement
qu'il faut méditer sur la fin tragique
de l'ami du chef de l'état c'est malgré
la pression engendrée par la campagne
des municipales
personne ne s'est levé pour dire ça
tombe bien personne ne s'est demandé
publiquement qui a tué roger patrice
pelât et surtout personne ne profite de
la situation pour relancer la faire dans
nos pays latins la décence veux que la
mort soit comme l'argent toujours
discret d'ailleurs il aura fallu la
fierté chine et pour que le nom de roger
patrice pelât sort de l'ombre
il aura fallu attendre de connaître ses
relations privilégiées avec françois
mitterrand pour que les projecteurs se
braquent sur lui une enquête
parfaitement légal de la commission des
opérations en bourse
une instruction judiciaire tout à fait
traditionnelle roger patrice pelât s'est
il senti victime de la rumeur de la
calomnie
toujours est il qu'au moment de sa mort
rien n'était révélé
il n'y avait à son encontre que des
présomptions mais l'impact des
présomptions et difficilement
contrôlables a fortiori sur un homme de
santé particulièrement fragile
aujourd'hui l'inculpation de recel de
délit d'initié contre monsieur place et
un d'elle-même mais pour les autres
inculpés la justice comme on dit suit
son cours selon ses proches françois
mitterrand est resté toute la journée
impénétrable
merci jean louis vii tragédie maintenant
quinze morts à belfort un incendie en
plein centre-ville des scènes d'horreur
la nuit dernière dans cet immeuble où
habitait de nombreux jeunes étudiants de
l'université
agnès poirier l'alerté donnée à 3 heures
du matin quand les pompiers arrivent sur
place dans ce vieux quartier de belfort
l'immeuble est tout entier
la proie des flammes horrible
insupportable des hurlements des flammes
partout raconte ce témoin la cage
d'escalier où le feu a pris s'est
effondré et locataires sont bloquées
dans les étages
pris de panique quatre personnes se
jettent par la fenêtre et se tue
l'ancien hôtel avait été rénové et
aménagé en meublé il ya sept ans dans
les 30 studios des jeunes principalement
et quelques personnes âgées
beaucoup ont été surpris dans leur
sommeil
quatorze personnes ont trouvé la mort
dans cet incendie ce soir les pompiers
ne cachaient pas leur amertume et les
survivants leur colère d'extérieur à
peut-être été refaits nous confier un
locataire mais pas l'intérieur
impossible de savoir encore comment la
110e déclaré une enquête est ouverte
une grande première dans la
communication gouvernementale le premier
ministre et le ministre de l'éducation
face aux téléspectateurs c'était tout à
l'heure sur antenne 2 fr3 et chaînes de
radios publiques pendant trois quarts
d'heure les deux responsables du secteur
éducation et donc de la réforme jospin
ont répondu aux questions
chantal kimmerlin c'était en effet une
première pendant trois quarts d'heure le
premier ministre le ministre de
l'éducation ont tenté de répondre aux
interrogations et aux inquiétudes des
téléspectateurs et des auditeurs
plus de 3000 appels enregistrés svp une
majorité d'enseignants et de nombreux
parents d'élèves
michel rocard et lionel jospin c'était
bien partager les deux rôles lionel
jospin a donné l'explication texte du
projet éducatif tandis que michel rocard
tenait les cordons de la bourse
pendant près de 30 minutes débat était
consacrée aux problèmes de la
revalorisation du métier il y a accor je
crois sur les grandes orientations que
je propose au nom du gouvernement mais
il y a blocage et insatisfaction sur la
revalorisation des enseignants
en ce qui concerne les grandes
orientations je dirais que le premier
élément c'est que nous voulons comme
c'est naturel centre et l'école sur
l'enfant et sur le jeune
nous avons décidé d'augmenter d'une fois
et demie la promesse électorale vous ne
font pas les deux premières années 4
mais si c'est à dire nous débordons la
promesse il y a de quoi mettre la
machine économique française presque en
péril c'est le cas limite lactée
deuxième partie du débat en réponse aux
questions de svp
michel rocard et lionel jospin se sont
attachés à rassurer les enseignants et
les parents sur les rumeurs qui courent
actuellement contre le projet éducatif
pas question de supprimer l'école
maternelle pas plus que les
redoublements le soutien aux élèves en
difficulté est maintenu sous plusieurs
formes et les enseignements artistiques
et sportives seront développés enfin les
deux hommes ont fait le point sur une
autre rumeur persistante et politique
le premier ministre et le ministre de
l'éducation n'ont aucune divergence
réaction immédiate des syndicats le snu
des instituteurs et le snes des profs du
secondaire ont écouté avec attention les
propos de michel rocard et lionel jospin
dominique laurie une première également
dans les bureaux d'antenne 2 les états
majors des deux grandes organisations
le syndicat national des instituteurs et
le syndicat des enseignants du second
degré
suivent en direct l'émission sourire
quand les deux hommes précise qu'il
s'entende bien satisfaction lorsque
michel rocard défend le métier
d'enseignant déception au snes lors ce
qu'ils abordent la revalorisation et que
nous avons dû le même discours que celui
qui était venu avant cette puissante
manifestation de la passion que membre
du gouvernement présent à l'antenne non
temps de rien pour sa part le secrétaire
général du smi à trouver des éléments
très positifs dans cette émission des
insulteurs à son compte
ces sont des réponses qui devait être
dur à faire qu'on discute vraiment sur
la réalité de ce qu'ils proposent et mes
chaussons rouges et le bal pop à nice
c'est vrai ça bouge parce que le
syndicat n'est bâti et fait évoluer
losier ils feront quand elle bouge pas
mal avant que duchaussoy
l'actualité sociale elle est chargée ce
soir vous allez le voir avec d'abord une
bonne nouvelle tout de même la fin du
conflit de la comatex c'est la société
qui nettoie le métro parisien
les grévistes ont accepté les
propositions de la direction après trois
semaines de grève
le salaire minimum est porté à 5200
francs et 35 salariés intérimaires sont
intégrés les internes en médecine en
revanche ont décidé de poursuivre leur
mouvement ils veulent être reçus par le
ministre de la santé
les infirmières anesthésistes poursuivre
leur mouvement elle aussi les hôpitaux
fonctionnent mal donc en ce moment car
les internes sont un des rouages
essentiels de ces hôpitaux problème
responsabilités d'un interne
daniel duigou
ce matin aux urgences de l'hôpital
broussais à paris cet interne de garde
en chirurgie à 27 ans il fait partie des
20 % d'étudiants en médecine
sélectionnés sur concours pour se former
à l'hôpital dans une spécialité une voie
royale qui se paye très cher d'abord ces
semaines font entre 90 et 110 heures
avec une nuit sur quatre de garde
ensuite ses responsabilités sont énormes
il assure des admissions des opérations
des consultations le tout sous le
contrôle du chef de clinique
c'est pourquoi les internes refusent
d'être considérés comme des étudiants
savent pas des étudiants nous sommes des
médecins spécialistes en formation parce
que nous avons encore des choses à
apprendre et tout chirurgien tout
médecin doit reconnaître qu'il a des
choses à apprendre toute sa vie mais
nous sommes avant tout des médecins et
des chirurgiens responsables qui sont
seuls et praticiens hospitaliers des
enseignants des plus jeunes
et accessoirement parfois des tâcherons
de la médecine hospitalière
l'inter n'est payée par l'hôpital mais
mal payés la première année après sept
ans d'études 5900 francs par mois
la quatrième année après 11 ans d'études
9700 francs à ce salaire s'ajoutent les
gardes de nuit seulement 15 francs de
leur système tel qu'il nous est offert
pour le remettons pas en cause ce que
nous n'acceptons pas c'est de voir se
dévaloriser au sens salariat du terme au
sens tarification horaire d'une nuit du
terme
la fonction d'un terne avec les
responsabilités qui lui incombent au
quotidien et pendant la nuit
les internes sont donc inquiets inquiet
de leurs salaires inquiets de leur
avenir de plus en plus bouché un interne
sur deux seulement trouve un poste de
chef de clinique marchepied de
l'agrégation du professeur à et de la
responsabilité d'un service enfin les
internes sont inquiets de l'avenir de
l'hôpital qui n'a plus de projet faute
d'une politique claire et faute de
moyens financiers suffisants
enfin un autre conflit celui des
messageries de presse les nmpp
c'est pour cela que vous n'avez pas une
journaux dans beaucoup de régions pâte
quotidien non plus demain ni date de
madère ils ne seront pas distribués un
vrai problème à quatre jours du premier
tour des municipales
tout cela est dû à une grève d'une
partie des ouvriers du livre c
j'étais stéphane magnier symbole et
causes réelles du conflit ces machines
les rotatives ultramoderne qui doivent
bouleversé l'impression et la
distribution des quotidiens tous les
grands groupe hersant maxwell ont leurs
projets les premiers opérationnel ici à
ivry sur le monde et le parisien libéré
ils emploieront 300 personnes un tiers
de moins qu'avant mise en service mi
mars
autant dire que les ouvriers du livre
cgt qui ont déclenché le conflit
ce sont à la fois menacé est à court de
temps la tension ne date pourtant pas
d'hier
les négociations pour éviter la crise
sociale où commencer il y à plus d'un an
c'est vrai qu'il ya des négociations qui
sont en cours depuis plus d'un an mais à
aucun moment nous n'avons pu avant frais
à aucun moment aucun éditeur n'a précisé
sa position canton de vaud quant à sa
place qu'il entendait garder au niveau
du système de distribution actuel
conséquence un conflit qui a stoppé la
distribution des quotidiens dans toute
la france aujourd'hui et demain puisque
la grève a été reconduite pour 24 heures
ce qui veut dire que les hebdomadaires
seront touchées à leur tour pourtant
alors qu'aucune négociation nouvelle n'a
été entamée les ouvriers du livre ne
semblait pas vouloir faire monter la
tension trop longtemps nous avons
clairement conscience que nous sommes à
quatre jours des municipales fait
pourquoi vraisemblablement à partir de
demain
l'action sera prise sous une autre forme
en consultation avec l'enfant de des
travailleurs pour ne pas compromettre
cette petite chance d'ouverture la
direction préfère rester discrète et
mettre en place un système de
distribution de rechange de toute façon
tout le monde est convaincu qu'il s'agit
de la première bataille d'un conflit à
rebondissements les municipales j - 4 ce
soir la belle histoire de l'île de
molène
c'est une île de bretagne au large de
brest et pourtant elle manque de nerf il
y un mois on parlait déjà de l'île de
molène parce qu'elle manquait d'eau à
cause de la sécheresse et bien cette
fois on en parle parce qu'elles ne
trouvent pas de maire il y avait bien
une liste électorale mais personne ne
veut se déclarer pour être premier
magistrat
reportage à molène bruno roger-petit et
christian leroux les vieux marin
prétendent que les étrangers ne sont pas
les bienvenus sur l'île molène
du silence une petite île où l'on ne
garde pas sa voiture mais son bateau une
île qui a chassé son boulanger il ya
quinze ans parce qu'on n'aimait pas son
pain une île enfin où l'on se méfie
toujours des regards inconnu depuis 24
ans auguste de la ruelle au maire de
bollène seul cet autodidacte a apporté
sur l'île l'électricité l'eau courante
mais là c'est de taper lui même ces
arrêtés municipaux
il veut passer la main après 24 ans
parce qu'un quart de siècle en effet je
pense que cela suffit et je vais en même
temps que les jeunes prennent conscience
de leur capacité à gérer
nous sommes peut-être pas sont peut-être
certaine appréhension
si tout à fait normal qu'ils se
rassurent j'en avais les mêmes 24 ans
appréhension mais aussi méfiance car
s'il ya bien une liste et une seule
aucun des 19 candidats qui la composent
ne se déclare personne ne parle
sur l'île de silence on est avare de
confidences et il faut attendre le
crépuscule à marée basse
un rendez vous secret au vieux phare
pour qu'une langues se délient et
explique pourquoi personne ne veut de la
mairie ce qui serait susceptible d'être
mère attend d'être élu au conseil
municipal
pourquoi ne se déclare tune pas
maintenant pour plus de sécurité pour
pas passer votre avis ils s'y sont pas
s'ils sont prades
si son pays ainsi quoi qu'il arrive
molène aura bien un nouveau maire mais
personne ne révélera jamais les secrets
de cette élection
du marin molène restera l'île du silence
les policiers mieux formés c'est
l'objectif du ministre de l'intérieur
pierre joxe qui a présenté son plan il y
explique les nouvelles exigences pour la
formation de la police
l'idée générale il s'agit d'élever le
niveau emmanuel vanier objectif préparer
la police à l'europe de 1993
le but de cette nouvelle charte de
formation rendre les cent dix mille
policiers français plus efficace et plus
proche des citoyens
trois mesures principales elles devront
s'appliquer en cinq ans à partir de
cette année le recrutement les tests
d'aptitudes psychologique prendront plus
d'importance pour les gardiens le niveau
bac sera exigée contre le bepc
aujourd'hui pour les inspecteurs deux
années d'études supérieures
le bac jusqu alors été suffisant pour
les commissaires la maîtrise au lieu de
la licence actuellement la scolarité
elle passe de 8 à 12 mois pour un
gardien de la paix la lutte contre la
toxicomanie l'une des principales causes
de la délinquance 200 super flics anti
drogue seront formés l'accent sera
également mis sur la formation de
l'encadrement sur l'accueil du public et
sur l'aide aux victimes
un programme ambitieux qui nécessite de
très importants moyens financiers
les crédits consacrés à la formation
vont augmenter dès cette année de près
de 40% pour atteindre 63 millions de
francs l'affairé rushdie avec beaucoup
d'informations encore aujourd'hui logis
hier une organisation terroriste a dit à
beyrouth qu'elle était prête à exécuter
l'écrivain britannique s'apprête même
logis air détient des otages américains
au liban elle emboîte ainsi le pas du
jihad islamique
tout à l'heure on a appris que la grande
bretagne avait décidé d'expulser des
iraniens de son territoire pour des
raisons de sécurité ces mesures
toucheront même des iraniens membres de
l'ambassade d'iran à londres la grande
bretagne d'autre part demande à ses
ressortissants de quitter le liban une
nouvelle fois donc la tension s'accroît
entre l'islam et les pays occidentaux
l'islam qui continue de montrer sa force
un exemple l'algérie le référendum le
mois dernier a mis fin à 25 ans de parti
unique
aussitôt des partys islamique se sont
créés c'est la nouvelle donne de la vie
politique algérienne
bruno le dress
en algérie c'est ce qu'on appelle le
référendum quotidien chaque jour que
fait dieu par centaines de milliers les
musulmans prennent le chemin de la
mosquée les votes avec leurs prières
sous les directions des imams
personnalité ou tant religieuse que
politique
une bonne partie des fidèles est composé
des 20 % de chômeurs du pays
une manière comme une autre de s'occuper
mais l'islam algérien est également
populaire chez les jeunes
exemple l'université de bouzaréah
c'est sic officie chez rabasse madani
professeur en sciences de l'éducation et
prédicateurs intégristes il vient de
créer le front islamique du salut
le premier parti politique musulman de
l'histoire algérienne la prière c'est
politique
il n'y a pas un parti qui peut
rassembler ce militant cinq fois par
jour comme nous le faisons avec la
prière est ce que vous ne croyez pas
fait peur aux autres partis politiques
en disant ça justement nous ne faisons
peur qu un juste à ceux qui accaparent
les richesses
nous sommes pour l'enrichissement moral
et matériel notre mission est de sortir
notre peuple du cercle vicieux de la
crise nous sommes le meilleur parti
car nous sommes plus proches du peuple
que le fln est plus prêt dit bhl que lui
vous voulez prendre le pouvoir
c'est donc par hippolyte taine warda à
notre programme bien du prophète mahomet
le pouvoir est un moyen pas une fin
aujourd'hui les islamistes militants
représentent une force importante la
seule qui pour l'instant peut s'opposer
au fln mais demain la montée en
puissance de nouveaux partis pourraient
bien les marginalisés politiquement les
renvoyer dans les mosquées les invités à
s'intéresser désormais au seul problème
religieux comme le souhaite par exemple
ces militantes
elle était cet après midi quelques
milliers devant l'assemblée nationale
manifestation féministe organisée pour
protester contre les déclarations d'un
imam
ils réclamaient le retour des femmes
sous la stricte le coup de la loi
coranique
une manifestation soutenue par le fln et
l'ensemble des nouveaux partis algériens
dans cette algérie en pleine mutation
une nouvelle société laïque est en train
de naître
malgré les appels à la prière
j'ajoute que françois mitterrand se rend
demain en algérie une visite importante
à tous points de vue car les relations
entre les deux pays sont toujours
délicates et émotionnel voici une
affaire dont on parlera probablement
probablement par dans la ferme et 6 lits
mais s'il y un avocat français d'origine
algérienne a battu en france il ya deux
ans son meurtrier présumé avait été
arrêté mais il avait été expulsé
discrètement sa femme demande
aujourd'hui que justice soit faite
rémy roche briser le mur du silence
depuis deux ans elle se bat pour que la
justice passe pour que celui qu'elle
croit être l'assassin de son mari ne
soit plus protégé au nom de la raison
d'état
au nom des bonnes relations entre la
france et l'algérie ali mais s'il y
était avocat il était aussi celui qui
avait réussi le rapprochement entre
harnes achmed et benguela au nom de
l'unité de l'opposition au régime du
président chadli un rôle qui lui aurait
selon ses amis valu d'être abattue sur
ordre des services secrets algériens
alors que ses avocats veulent relancer
l'action judiciaire elle écrit au
président de la république je tiens à
lui rappelé qu'un homme qui a défendu
toute sa vie des droits de l'homme qui a
défendu toute sa vie la justice est mort
assassiné à paris au mépris de la
souveraineté nationale
je voulais lui rappeler aussi que le
général de gaulle en son temps lors de
la ferme et marca avaient peut-être
manifester plus d'intransigeance et
avaient fait respecter la souveraineté
nationale
c'est donc dans l'espoir qu'avec le
président chadli bendjedid et les
autorités algériennes qui aujourd'hui
semble s'ouvrir aux idéaux que mon mari
a défendu toute sa vie j'espère qu'ils
feront tous les deux qu'ils essaieront
de faire tous les deux la lumière sur
cette affaire
halime syrie avaient été assassinés ici
alors qu'il rentrait dans le hall de son
immeuble une jeune femme qui l'avait
accompagné voit un homme qui s'enfuit à
pied peu de temps après un suspect est
interpellé un certain amellou proxénète
algérien il correspond au signalement du
tueur est chez lui on retrouve un ordre
de mission officielle de la sécurité
militaire algérienne mais à mélou est
discrètement expulsés vers alger
pourtant à l'époque les policiers
possédait déjà des renseignements
particulièrement accablant
une commission rogatoire internationale
a été lancée elle est pour l'instant
resté sans écho tout de suite d'autres
informations internationales à commencer
par cette décision du président de la
république l'elysée a fait annuler un
contrat d'exportation de missiles
mistral au congo éric perrin françois
mitterrand annuler un contrat prévoyant
la fourniture au congo de cinquante
missiles air-sol mistral selon
l'hebdomadaire l'événement du jeudi la
société matra qui fabrique ce missile
aurait reçu une demande apparemment
officiel avec en tête du gouvernement
congolais
mais il semble que le président du congo
denis sassou n'guesso n'ai jamais donné
son aval à l'achat ces missiles seraient
en fait destiné un pays figurant sur la
liste rouge
la société matra se déclarent tout à
fait clair dans cette affaire
une information judiciaire a été ouverte
contre l'intermédiaire qui avait produit
ses faux documents
déploiement de forces chinoises au tibet
pour ramener le calme après les trois
jours d'émeutes qui ont fait plusieurs
dizaines de morts tout ce début de
semaine plusieurs milliers de tibétains
ont manifesté violemment pour réclamer
l'indépendance de leur pays annexé en
1959 par la chine depuis l'instauration
hier de la loi martiale
la police a effectué de nombreuses
arrestations les rares touristes
présents à lhassa ont reçu l'ordre de
quitter le pays
le gouvernement en exil du dalaï lama a
condamné la loi martiale tout en
précisant qu'il était toujours prêt à
discuter avec la chine
aussitôt après le journal dans quelques
minutes un très beau film de serge moati
l'été de tous les chagrins il va
inaugurer une nouvelle collection
d'antenne 2 une collection baptisée
sentiment l'été de tous les chagrins
c'est la fin de la guerre d'algérie à
travers les yeux d'un enfant
georges beyney ton père s'est impatienté
juillet
on commence à faire jouer tu sais je
supporte pas ce qu'est ce que tu dises
qu'ils allaient mourir ça suffit de
faire belle france anthony rota voilà
occulte pas de lui
serge moati nous raconte une histoire
émouvante forte
pareil à la sienne dans une afrique du
nord à la veille de l'indépendance dont
il entretient à paris trente ans après
le pieux souvenir un enfant de 10 ans va
perdre à la fois sans trop comprendre
ses parents et son pays
j'ai vécu à la fois là la fin de d'un
monde qui éteignent un d'un enfant choyé
entourée et aimée par ses parents
formidables et en même temps la cassure
historique c'est à dire le départ d'un
pays
le départ vers la france que je
connaissais pas il fait froid c'est pas
le même truc expérience donc j'ai vécu
la fin de mon monde et la fin d'un monde
qui était la france en afrique du nord
et vous culpabiliser y est comme
l'enfant qu'on voit dans le film est là
sous savez je crois que les enfants
lorsqu'ils perdent leurs parents ils se
disent mais c'est parce que j'ai pas été
gentil j'ai fait quelque chose qu'il
fallait pas j'ai pas été bien sinon mes
parents serait pas mort
bonsoir c'est beaucoup pour moi année où
on a tiré sur leur voiture et je
m'entends tu comprends j'en ai assez
d'entendre la haine la haine entre les
communautés la haine pour les religions
la haine pour les arabes
nous on se connaissait et on sait mais
il n'y a pas de raison qu'on puisse m'en
parler avec respect et avec tendresse le
temps efface les haines passagère et ce
qui reste des souvenirs d'amitiés et
cette amitié malgré caricature qu'en
font les extrémistes de tous poils en ce
moment cette amitié elle est faite est
très importante et très solide entre les
différentes communautés qui composent et
d'afrique du nord et qui composent
curieusement la france de maintenant
voilà c'est ce très beau film que vous
verrez aussitôt après la météo présentée
dans quelques instants par laurent
cabrol laurent qui annonce un temps
plutôt agréable à 22h15 les années bio
un nouveau volet de l'histoire immédiate
daniel leconte présente tout ce qui se
fait de nouveau et d'extraordinaire dans
la biologie des manipulations génétiques
aux recherches sur le cancer et le sida
dernière édition ce sera philippe gassot
vers 23h35 et puis ensuite le basket
avec le match limoges barcelone en coupe
d'europe alors amateurs de paniers à vos
postes demain matin 7h premier journal
de la rédaction présentée par marc
hautement et catherine ceylac dans
télématin bonne soirée sur antenne 2 à
demain 20 heures